Chris Miller is the former acting
Secretary of Defense the author of
soldier secretary he joins us tonight Mr
Miller thank you so much for coming on
forging an alliance between Russia and
China seems like the end of American
power in a lot of the world and a
massive new threat that dwarfs anything
Putin has ever done in Ukraine why would
they allow this to happen do they want
this to happen what's the thinking do
you know Tucker first I have to go there
Vivek just announced that he's going to
run for president did I hear that right
in the last segment he did yes that's
just amazing so I'm literally second
fiddle but you know he basically gave I
thought a great foreign policy lay down
for where we should be going forward on
this your question though I I got to
tell you you know the president I'm
going to give him props for you know his
speech writers gave a pretty good speech
and uh you know I look forward to him
coming back to the United States and
going out to Palestine Ohio or going
down in the border and saying the same
sort of things that's irony Tucker you
know that because I'm Generation X and
I'm like a letterman guy right so my
point simply is we spend a trillion
dollars a year on National Defense and
my point from my book is holy cow that
we have to look at this differently and
we need to bring that money home and
spend it on things here in America to
make America stronger your point about
China and Russia is so valid I I'll be a
little bit uh counter factual on you or
a little bit iconoclastic I think uh
chairman G and the Chinese Communist
party you're laughing all the way to the
bank right now is they make as they play
as they play us again
well sure but you know military and
economic alliances are going to affect
our economy and you've got to think
China's primary goal is to make money
right I mean it's a it's a business
slash government and if China and Russia
are alive China providing I mean Russia
providing the the raw materials I mean
this just makes the Chinese trade block
much bigger and US much weaker does it
not
yeah with the 2500 mile border between
China and Russia and with Russia focused
on Ukraine to the West right now I got
to thank the Chinese Communist party is
just licking their lips going yeah this
we couldn't ask for better because you
know as well as I do they have serious
limitations on their natural resources
and it all lies to the north so you know
it's a little bit of an off the wall uh
answer but I think the Chinese are
playing the long game you know we we as
you highlight so much on on your show is
we have this short View and we need and
frankly Vivek said the same thing you
know we have to look long term and I
think the Chinese probably are playing
us both pretty well of course they are
as always and we're letting Chris Miller
thank you so much for joining us tonight
thanks for having me talk a really
important issues thanks for the hard
hitting journalism you're doing thank
you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight